Selena Gomez had a footwear mishap at
the 2022 SAG Awards the moment became
the answer to a popular question people
asked during the broadcast why is Selena
Barefoot on stage put simply it's
because she's a professional who knows
The Show Must Go On it's amazing you
just wait here's what went down
that's Selena stunning in her Oscar de
la Renta gown now this next part
happened mostly off camera but anyone
can see in the moment shortly after
Selena actually tripped on the red
carpet
thankfully some nearby Heroes helped the
star get back on her feet and Selena
safely made her way inside
where she was set to present alongside
her only murders in the building co-star
Martin Short when ashamed the great
Steve Martin couldn't join us tonight
for the three of us are really a family
and that we often eat meals together in
total Style
but her Louboutin
songs were apparent
invited I wanted to come at things with
my best eagle-eyed fans immediately
noticed Selena was barefoot when she
stepped on stage Buffy ordeal didn't
seem to mess with Selena's comedic
timing he was excited I'm excited yes
I'm excited too although it's hard for
me to express my excitement because the
botox is fresh
thank you
[Applause]
all right mine too and the actor goes
too Selena continued to look unfazed
throughout the night remaining shoeless
even as she chatted it up with some big
names
Nicole Kidman Lady Gaga and Jared Leto
all witnessed Selena's last minute
fashion solve up close
thankfully nothing could stop the 29
year old singer on the big night she was
also celebrating her first sag award
nomination following her performance and
only murders in the building I think we
should just hit him with the charm good
excellent so I'll take the lead on this
excuse me well I can turn on the charm
is it on now
it's warming up Selena and the all-star
cast earned a nod for outstanding
performance by an ensemble in a comedy
series the premiere of season 2 is still
a long way out but Selena is sharing fun
behind the scenes Antics like these to
Tick-Tock hey
um so how did you get into collecting
art yep that's the actress on set
trolling her comedy Legend co-stars just
check out this epic eye roll oh that's
really really interesting because I
started a very very young and I used my
eyes to look at Art I didn't know you
used your eyes no I thought you kind of
felt it and sensitive right so that's
just with a live model
[Music]